a lot of those who
feel instinctively embarrassed about
britain's past
don't know very much about it
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is the
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant and fantastic guest today
is the regis professor
of moral and pastoral theology nigel
bigger welcome to trigonometry thanks
very much
it's so great to have you we're here at
oxford university it's a pleasure to be
here and speaking with you which is of
course where you
you work before we get into a very
interesting uh background and story just
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life that leads you
to this very strange place
sitting in this chair on youtube okay
well i wasn't born in oxford i was born
in scotland uh but my scottish accent
got drained from me when i came south to
school the
age of 13 except when i'm when i'm
slightly drunk or
[Laughter]
when i'm in the pulpit i can get quite
scottish
otherwise otherwise not so i've i've
developed an academic career i've i
spent about seven years in canada in the
states
uh collected my wife there brought her
back about 30 years ago
and have taught here in oxford in leeds
in dublin
and then for the last 11 years have
taught back here in oxford
and my my field i i have this
rather bizarre title professor of moral
and pastoral theology
what's that basically it's ethics
but it's ethics done from a religious
christian point of view
um so i teach that and i do i've done
research on
i've written on things like the ethics
of
the euthanasia um published a book on
the ethics of war
uh i also do peace i've done i've done
stuff on
um making peace and doing justice after
civil conflict
northern ireland south africa and just
about
to bring out a book on rights so it's
fair to say in summary that you've had a
distinguished academic
career but i think people who will be
aware of you
us included first became aware of you in
november 2017.
um when that laugh is exciting
i remember that i'm sure you do
see it into the memory no dab when you
wrote a piece for the times which was
entitled don't feel guilty
about our colonial past which was a
defense of your colleague bruce gilley
uh who'd written something about you
know the empire and colonialism not
being
all bad so tell us briefly about that
and what happened and
how that went okay so um
you you've described the article
appeared in the times in late november
2017 and by the way um
as you'll know when people write for
newspapers um
they don't have control over the of the
title but what i said in my article was
we brits
we have reason uh for pride as well as
shame
over the imperial pastor so our imperial
past is mixed they were awful things and
there were some great things
all i was saying was both which is a
pretty i thought was a pretty
unobjectionable moderate position that
no one really could disagree with
um more for me um um
so that the title is a bit
misrepresentative but that was published
in late november um
and then about a week about a week later
um i got around after six months uh
delay
publishing online uh a description of a
research project
that i had launched in july of 2017
called ethics and empire and this brings
together
a group of ethicists and historians
to to survey empire from ancient china
to the modern period
and consider the ways in which
contemporaries thought about
the empires they lived in in moral terms
and how did they see things
morally but i finally got around to
publishing a description of that online
and then a few days after that second
week of december
my wife and i were in uh the fancy
lounge at heathrow airport we were going
off to
uh celebrate our wedding anniversary
nuremberg not everyone's
choices sweetie doesn't help
i like history she likes christmas
markets um
and uh you know as you do i just had to
check my email one last time before
getting the plane and there was a an
email from
the public relations people here in
oxford
informing me that a group of students
calling themselves
common ground had published an online
denunciation of my ethics and empire
project um
so that i've never experienced that
before but that that was
uh told me and the good news was that
the
the university uh um said that it was
entirely behind my right to run such a
thing
so i didn't think any more of it um
but uh that was on the thursday on
on the sunday i got news from my main
historical collaborator
that he was he was resigning for the
project and
in the next four days there were two
more
online denunciations these last two by
academics
of of this project that i was running
so that all of that together in that
week was was a bit of a shock
and i i um i really not been expecting
it at all
clearly looking back i was naive um
[Music]
um is this sort of thing just to
interrupt very briefly is this sort of
thing standard practice in academia
where
people take exception to a particular
topic of research and then there's a
student campaign and then academics
resign and withdraw from
participation is that normal or is this
unusual
that that's a good question it wasn't
normal i mean i'd never experienced it
before
um but i think it's become much more
normal
uh certainly i've i we're all aware of
cases in the last
three or four years where that's
happened to people
and of course of course social media
enables that kind of thing
uh it enables an individual to write a
protest and then
send it around to all their mates all
over the world and within
a matter of hours you may have collected
several hundred signatures
which looks really powerful um
i mean in in in the months in the weeks
and months that i spent
trying to come to terms with what was
going on
i did come to the view that this was not
an appropriate way for
academic colleagues to behave um
because when i complained about these
online denunciations from in one case 58
oxford colleagues and then in the in the
third
um protest there were i think about 200
academics worldwide um i mean they said
oh
we were simply uh um trying to stimulate
a conversation
i said well you know if you if you want
a conversation
i mean some of the people who signed
these letters
uh two of them work across the road from
me
they know my door is in fact two of them
were in the same college as me in this
college
they know what my door is they could
have come and spoken to me they didn't
and they haven't since um
and so so the notion this was a kind of
invitation to conversation
uh is complete baloney
um i can only interpret it as of course
it's an aggressive thing to do but it
was
designed
perhaps to intimidate me or
also to persuade university authorities
to act against me in some way by pulling
funding or
some other kind of of sanction and
why do you think this is happening more
and more that we have this emboldened
minority who feel that they have the
right
not to criticize because it is
absolutely their right to criticize your
work or
your views or whatever else it may be
but they feel that they have the right
to cancel something that's a really good
question
and i i continue to puzzle over it um
many people have always had strong
political opinions
and within universities you know there
are people in people on on the
far left and the further right that's
always been the case
um i i can only
speculate that
um the kind of people who
think they have that right are people
who have spent a long time talking to
people of their own kind
and so it really appears to them as if
there is only one
view of these things um
that's one possibility the the other the
other possibility is that
um not only do they are they convinced
that a certain
view of the world is is right and and
they have it
um but that that the contrary view of
the world
is absolutely unacceptable
i mean i uh um um the word the word
fascist
is thrown out all over the place if you
if you
if you utter a conservative right-wing
opinion you're a fascist
um so immediately you're pushed into the
extreme
um so it's not it's not just as it were
people operating in a kind of
intellectual bubble where they they
they never really hear a contradiction
and they're constantly confirming what
what what they and their their mates
think it's also that there's a tendency
somehow to demonize the opposition
uh in ways that um
quite how they come to that view i just
don't understand
although to be honest i mean i i see a
lot of it in the pages of the guardian
now i mean i i
i surely not yeah well yeah yeah well it
didn't used to be that way when i there
was a time
i will confess when i think of the 90s
that the guardian was the only paper i
read
um but it's become more and more
um um fixated with
identity politics and um
that kind of politics doesn't seem to
it's not into compromise um
and uh it does tend to
demonize the opposition in in ways that
the left hasn't always done
and
i don't quite understand why that's the
case i mean
let's be clear uh in the past um the far
right has done that
we all know that from from uh 20th
century history
uh from real fascism in france and
germany and
italy um but it's it's it's not
that kind of um othering and
demonization
um does at the moment seem to come from
certain parts of the left
and it's it's very interesting that you
say that and
we were talking about academia what
happened to you do you think there's a
problem with free speech on campus
yes i do um
the left will disagree
again if you read the guardian you'll
find a number of people in recent years
saying
a concern about freedom of speech is is
really
a fabrication by people like me
male white elderly who are
alarmed of having our accustomed
authority drained away from us
um so no one listens to us and so we're
upset and so we complain about our
freedom of speech being
suppressed and that is just not true
and i know it partly from my own direct
experience
um and partly through recent
social scientific surveys one published
a couple of weeks ago
but just in terms of my own experience i
mean i
i'm coming to toward the end of my
career i'm in a procedure position
it's quite hard to get to me um
at least that's clear no it wasn't clear
to me in december 2017
uh but i'm i'm secure um so did you
think at the time that you were likely
to
lose your job i had no idea but but i i
lost
night's sleep over it yeah just partly
because um
yes because at least initially
i felt alone
[Music]
one of my oldest friends who i still
respect and love
[Music]
actually told me to abandon my project
straight away because he said it's just
too toxic
toxic and then
the fact that my my senior
collaborator on the project resigned
within four days
giving an implausible explanation
for his abrupt resignation and then um
um
yes from colleagues
here on the whole silence
so you do you know i did begin to wonder
am i crazy am i daft
and although the university had
indicated from the beginning that it
would
back me up
yes i guess i i did feel quite
vulnerable and not quite sure
where this was going to go um
fortunately you survived yeah yeah but
your concern is that
you know you are in a prestigious
position as you say coming towards the
end of your career yeah
a younger colleague yeah absolutely
so that that's that's the concern um
and i have plenty of experience of of
younger colleagues
who um are conservative in
in their views who have said to me
you know really pleased that you are
saying what you're saying
nigel um uh i just couldn't dare to say
it myself and i i've actually said to
oh in fact they've said you know i feel
guilty that i'm not saying
the same thing and i said to them well
you know nor should you at this point
you need to wait until you get tenure
and then
then you can start to say what you think
when you're secure but right now
you need to play the long game um
but there was one one um
one instance of a very junior academic
a junior research fellow who was an
academic who hasn't got a permanent job
yet
he's got the he had his phd he's got a
kind of three-year research post
and then has to look for a permanent job
so it's quite insecure
and in uh in may 2018
are you talking about noah carl no i'm
not no no no
he will this guy must remain nameless
for reasons
um no this is this was uh
uh this was a a historian
and i i uh you mentioned bruce gilley
who published this
uh uh provocative but in my view uh
intelligent article called the case for
colonialism
um i had gilly come here in may 2018 and
we held in this room
a small conference with um
[Music]
some historians uh paul collier the
development economist
tutenko rye the um the
historian of colonial economics in his
in india and others uh because i i
i wanted to to generate a
a kind of intelligent um
reflective discussion about what gilly
was saying about
colonialism but because i didn't want to
invite
um heckling
and also because frankly small
gatherings
are much better in terms of conversation
than large ones
and because they fit 30 people in this
room i didn't advertise it i just
invited people i thought would be good
to have part of the conversation
and one of them was this young junior
research fellow who i i
we'd had a clandestine conversation
uh um in a distant part of the
university where he he revealed that he
actually liked what i had to say um
i kid you not we actually had to find a
place where he didn't think he'd be
recognized
um and he said yes i'd love to come
but but in two conditions um
my name must not appear in the list of
participants and if you're taking
photographs my face
must not appear because he said um
i i work in the same office as two
senior colleagues
uh two of whom sign one of the letters
against you if they find out
that i've been associated with you i
fear for my
my career but nigel don't you find that
rather ridiculous that somebody can have
right of center opinions or even
opinions on the right and all of a
sudden their career
that you know is curtailed stunted
fired all the rest of it i mean it isn't
that's pathetic isn't it
that's pathetic and it's alarming uh
because you know this is this is oxford
um not oxford bricks yes
absolutely i didn't think so yes but
just to make that point perhaps for
people who haven't been to oxford who
haven't
been in the in the in this place it is
you know francis lives in london i live
just outside
coming here there there is a sense of
history to this place there is a sense
that this is one of the great places of
learning
in human history and as you walk around
in these buildings
these holes that feeling that this is a
place of learning is very strong here
and to hear that sort of attitude
being spread in in this place
is alarming at a very different level
than if it was happening alex brooks
do you know what i mean yeah well i i i
don't understand
you said you said that not me um but yes
i mean oxford and cambridge uh
according to to world rankings regularly
in the top 10 in the world so this is a
serious research university
as you say constantine it has a long
history of
uh serious um
perhaps not terribly exciting but
serious scholarship
uh careful fastidious um
yeah so so the fact that um a colleague
here
fears for his career because
um he might be known to be associated
with
such as me is really alarming actually
um now
let me be clear i i'm not saying
that um political censorship in oxford
is widespread i have no idea
um i'm sure that many colleagues don't
don't censor um
don't apply political criteria when
they're making appointments or when
they're writing references for
for junior scholars i'm sure many don't
do that
um so it may only be a minority uh who
are so politically convinced of their
own views that they will
penalize a colleague
a junior colleague a vulnerable junior
colleague by
writing them a pro reference because of
his political views
but here's the thing
even if it's only one in 10 or even 1 in
20
if you know some people do that the
effect on the general
once that becomes known the effect on
the general atmosphere is to make
everyone
look over their shoulders just wonder
who's listening to me what will the
effect be
um and that's really bad news really bad
news
um and nigel don't you think it's an
abdication of responsibility on behalf
of the universities because they should
absolutely crack down on this type of
behavior and say that it is not
acceptable
yeah i do i do so here's what here's one
point
in this university our vice chancellor
louise richardson has been
uh consistent
in affirming free speech of the
universities and its importance
and that's really that is important
because uh
the leader of an institution does set
the tone
and that just reminds people that this
is an important value
but what that doesn't do is change the
behavior of my junior
colleagues senior colleagues in their
office
it doesn't change the as it were um
um undercover operation of political
political criteria um
and so um something does need to be done
about that now
what could universities do about that
basically i think the university has to
recognize
that it is a problem and i've
i've i've written about this in in the
press
over the last three years there's an
in-house
magazine called the oxford magazine and
i published an article
on this point uh in early 2018
and the article ended um diversity is
good
political diversity is good too isn't it
um since then certainly in response to
that article
and in general conversation i've heard
no one talk about it
so some people know about it some people
read about it no one talks about it
um uh but i think we do need to talk
about now it's difficult to talk about
um because we we all have political
views
and that's not the issue of course the
issue is
being aware of when uh you are
uh unfairly applying political political
criteria
to appointments or admissions or
whatever in so in the same way that you
know
we all now need to be uh careful if we
weren't careful before
to make sure that prejudices about
social class or race
don't influence unfairly the judgments
we make
and that's utterly that's entirely
acceptable and important
we now need to do the same with with
political views
and at the moment that's just not an
issue that has
risen up the agenda and i think
university leaders need
to start doing that um
i mean maybe the government could prob
them maybe the office for students can
start
rattling their cages and saying folks
you need to take this seriously
and that i think that may happen
but it'd be good to see universities
take the initiative rather than being
pushed by government when we interviewed
douglas murray for our first interview
he was of the opinion that if a
university did not
support free speech on campus that they
should be defunded which is
quite an extreme position i think would
you be in agreement with you know
the government taking a stronger hand
and actually saying to universities if
you don't do your job in
supporting different viewpoints then
they're going to be some sanctions put
in place
yes i do i do i i think um
government does need to remind
universities of their commitment to
academic freedom
most universities have formal
commitments to free speech
uh although there's a distinction here
it's one thing to um to guarantee free
speech
academic freedom is slightly different
because it has to do with what
professors can teach in their classes
what books they can assign to their
students what research they do
and i think free speech is better
protected than academic freedom
so academic freedom also needs to be
protected
and i think i think government should
should um communicate
to university leaders that it regards as
matters
as a really serious one um
if i can just i want to come back to
that point and i might lose it so bring
me back in a moment
but just on that i think there's a
really important
point to be made about what's an issue
what's at stake here
um to some extent what's at stake is
is the right of minorities
in this case political minorities
and conservatives are reckoned to be i
don't know about 15 percent
of the university professoriate um
the right of political minorities to be
able to speak freely without fear of
sanction
and that's important but what's to take
is even more important
um is this
in universities we are
um forming
future citizens we are our graduates
with their particularly in this
university with their prestigious
university degree will go on to
run companies run the bbc become
journalists
become editors and we are we are
training them
in ways of dealing with points of view
they really don't like
um uh
how to handle uh
a a debate or a discussion or a
controversy
uh on matters that get people very
excited
and and you can train them well we can
train them well badly
we can train them only to to see one
point of view
we can train them to instead of
treating what an alternative point of
view
has to say and considering what reasons
it might have
you can train them instead to say well
because he's a conservative because he's
a capitalist because he speaks up for
empire
it's only because he's trying to protect
his own economic interests
or his social status whatever so don't
take what he says seriously
uh just to try and um undermine um
the kind of the moral integrity of of
his position
now you can do that uh but but that but
one that when those graduates go out in
into uh the professions into
institutions
into public into the media uh if they
start behaving that way the whole of
public discourse is going to be infected
by polarization aggression
a refusal to hear um
and that's just one step away from
bloodshed because when people
are no longer trying to argue they're
fighting
and uh um uh fierce verbal fighting
is only a step away from the real stuff
so what's a stake really is not just the
protection of minority opinions
it's really the public good of a
citizenry
who know how to restrain themselves when
they hear things
they don't like um
feel obliged to do justice to what other
people say so when someone says
something
you don't like you you don't then
distort it before you address it you
take it as it stands
um um and then to give to to
give credit where credit is to you and
then then to come up with the reasons
you think this is bloody wrong
now that's that's a responsible rational
way to conduct
the many many many um
um controversies over
issues we all get excited about and we
need citizens
and journalists and editors and um
institutional leaders who know how to do
that and model it
uh because otherwise the whole public
life is is is going to become much more
fractious polarized as we see it has
done
in the usa well and increasingly here
too i think it's fair to say and i think
you make that point very well
nigel but speaking about some of the
issues on which is very difficult to
have these conversations now
it's the one we started with which is of
course empire and colonialism that is
something that
has become very heated the conversation
around that has become
uh with a very particular world view
let's say
are people wrong to to be so uh critical
of the
of the our imperial history i mean some
terrible things were done
during imperial times uh you know
whether it's the invention of
concentration camps during the war war
by the british or
many many other atrocities on the indian
subcontinent
and around the world should we not be
ashamed of our history
my view as a as a someone who identifies
himself
strongly as british but i care about
this country identify with its history
um and my view is if you if you love
something
you are therefore capable of shame and
looking back at
my british history yes there are things
i'm deeply ashamed about
and that the classic case would be
slavery which we we engaged in for 200
years so
um as i said at the beginning um
pride is well ashamed right so certainly
shame
but my view is that that the british
empire
in that respect uh containing moments of
awfulness as well as moments of
greatness
is no different from any nation-state
and no different from any other empire
um
any nation state that's been around for
a long time in
in the course of time will get to do
some awful things
well the mongols committed some
seriously big microaggressions of the
genghis khan didn't they
uh but do you think perhaps britain and
i'm not as someone i'm not british so
while i feel well i say i'm not british
i think at this point i sort of am
no you know oh you know uh
but you know what i mean i come from a
different place but i'm i've integrated
into this country but i i probably feel
less of an affinity with british history
uh than than you than you would uh
do you think that britain is essentially
being punished for its historical
success
because if it had been less successful
if it had been a sweden or a norway or
whatever
that engaged in some of these things on
a much smaller scale or not at all
simply by virtue of not being a powerful
player in the world stage
then we wouldn't be having this
conversation now you're exactly right
so you will have noticed that that no
one is interested in
in beating up uh the french empire
or the russian or the chinese or the
zulu
or the comanche empire in the states
they're interested mainly in the british
empire
why is that it's because the the british
empire
um even as it declined
it morphed into the american empire or
at least it
morphed into american global power and
um the british empire
was supportive of a lot of the
uh post-second world war post 1945
international institutions so the kind
of international order we have
the kind of international order against
which
china is presently chafing and russia
that liberal international order um
uh owes it was a lot to the british
empire
and and subsequent uh american power
so you're absolutely right the reason
that the british empire
is getting beaten up on is not it's not
about the past at all
it's about the present it's about um
hostility toward anglo-american
liberal capitalism um
and that's that that's that's why my my
interest in
in british empire is not
primarily and aquarian uh it's it's it's
not
really about the past except in so far
as
uh what we think about the past uh
shapes how we think about ourselves now
and it shapes the decisions we make in
the future so
uh one of the um
things that stimulated me to get stuck
into british empire
is scottish nationalism now i'm as i
said i'm scottish born
my mother's english an anglo-scot i'm a
brit
i belong to a multi a multi-national
state
and i really value that um
and so i'm i'm i am
strongly against scottish separation
but there is there's a story being told
by some scottish nationalists
which is if i can distill it britain
equals empire equals evil
and therefore to to break up britain to
separate scotland from the rest of the
uk
is an act of of uh national
uh self-purification yeah
now you know if if if britain you know
if
britain equaled nazism equal evil
separation quite a good idea but but i
happen to know enough about the british
empire to know it just wasn't of that
kind at all
and
i don't think that the british empire
was uh radically
at its heart at its root racist i don't
think it was
radically at its heart exploitative
um it included moments of racism and
moments of exploitation
but when you were talking earlier about
about what school kids do and don't know
about slavery and
you were saying that you know your
experience as a teacher
school kids do know about slavery i
suspect they probably know less about
the more than a century
that the british spent suppressing
slavery
um the slave trade across the atlantic
the slave trade across
the indian ocean in africa in india in
the middle east
for about well from 1807 onwards until
the end of the empire
one of the main preoccupations of the
empire was the suppression of slavery
and i think that's wonderful how many
kids know about that
let me just follow up on one thing if
you don't mind this is the really
interesting
point you made about that it's about the
present not about the past
so and if i'm understanding you
correctly what you're saying is
there is an agenda to undermine the
american liberal capitalism
of the world that dominates the world
and it's anti-west
anti-west agreed completely certainly i
see that
and the british empire is like the
founding
cornerstone of that so if you can pull
that out you can make the whole pyramid
fall
yeah and you and so what you do is you
you undermine by undermining the record
the historical record
you undermine as it were the moral
authority of the whole thing yeah
go ahead first and the question i wanted
to ask was
we do learn about the british empire at
schools but we don't learn about other
empires
so is it part of the problem the fact
they see british empire they see slavery
without realizing that essentially if
you wanted anything done in history you
needed slaves
we're just going to clip that and put it
out as the slogan of trigonometry
if you want anything done you need an
anton that's what you need
to think in the past yes yeah in the
past you're not recommending this
i mean well you see sir
[Laughter]
let me save yourself um that's
absolutely right so
so one of the really interesting things
that we've discovered in
this ethics and empire project which as
i said is looking at empires from
indian chinese modern period so far
we've got up to about 1600
and uh um when i was asking around
uh colleagues who know about let's say
arab empires or islamic empires saying
you know can you find me
a contemporary critic and they said
well no not really
and it turns out that um
and the same happened in the case of
ancient chinese empire
and the conclusion i've drawn is that
at those times in those places uh
empire was a fact of life uh
uh um you might you might not like
particular emperors you might not like
particular governments
the way in which the empire was governed
but empire as such was completely
unremarkable
and um the fact is that
most of the world has been has been
ruled by empires
um um up until i mean
even today um uh
china is a kind of empire
um certainly tibetans would think so
um certainly hong kong feels that way
right now
so it you know it's still going on um so
empire is a kind of fact of life
and as for for slavery yeah you're right
i mean everyone
was was into slavery not all slavery was
as nasty
as what went on in the sugar plantation
of the west indies or
suddenly southern american colonies uh
but some of it was quite nasty i mean
um some of those who were carted off
the slaves who were sold by west african
kings to
european traders and taken off to the to
the caribbean
uh had they stayed they might have had
the fate um
of joining several hundred others
upon the death of a king or being buried
alive
uh to join their master on his heavenly
journey
uh there are there are reports of
up to up to uh 1 500
slaves being sacrificed by be buried
alive
um um to mark the
the funerals of um african princes in
1790
um so you know slavery
and long before before african
kings started selling their uh
their slaves and the savior normally
would have been uh
prisons of war uh um captured from other
tribes
before they sold the europeans they were
selling to the arabs
for centuries so yeah i mean
this doesn't that doesn't um
doesn't excuse uh the the
cruelty of a lot of um
slavery in the west indies which the
british were involved in
but it does put it in context uh so if
we sinned
um there were lots of other sinners too
and many of them
had black skins
well that's a very controversial point
but
but it is absolutely true and the thing
that it seems to me is that
what what we have nowadays are
narratives like you talked about you
know
the british being evil being you know
and then white supremacy wouldn't know
that be thrown in as well
and if you contradine that narrative
even if you've got
facts and you know you can make a cogent
argument
it doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah that's
that's really strange
um but i've become more confident
and more heartened um the more i've got
stuck into
these issues because um
you know when it started when this when
i first suffered grief in december 2017
um i'd only begun to to work on
on making moral sense of british empire
and i i've done a lot more reading since
and the thing i'm most struck about is
how the people who behave in that way
um don't know what they're talking they
really don't know what they're talking
about and and there are some academics
who behave that way and they just don't
know what they're talking about
um and my sense is uh um
well it's my hope but my sense is that
the more this kind of behavior gets
exposed
and contradicted that the great british
public out there become more and more
appalled
and that's my hope um
and i also think
and i've certainly seen here how
really self-persuaded self-convinced
zealous minorities of students or even
of professors
uh can have it can acquire a kind of
dominance over a more uncertain
uh majority who don't particularly want
to get involved in this fight
um so my sense is out there and i
even within universities a majority of
people
i'm not very impressed by the kind of
behavior you've described
um and the more the more people who
speak up
and out against it and the more
outrageous this behavior becomes
i i think there's reason to hope
that the the stronger the reaction will
be
um so i'm not gloomy about this at all
but it's it's
it's a good point that you may you know
that you're not gloomy about it and
there seems to be a strong reaction i
think things came to a head a great deal
during the black lives matter
demonstrations right
whatever you want to call them the
tearing down of the statues where do you
stand on that you have you know the
famous example is edward colston
the slave trader and then it got torn
down do you do you agree with that or do
you think
that we actually should have those
statues in a prominent place
um
i i didn't agree with it being torn down
that way so first of all there's an
issue of process
yes and and for for a mob however
passionate they are to take it upon
themselves to pull stuff public stuff
down
is not acceptable because if if the left
can do that the right can start doing it
too folks
we don't want that so that that was just
wrong uh as for
colston himself
uh um
my view on statues is this um
i mean there are some people in history
whose record is pretty irredeemable
to take the obvious examples adolf
hitler goebbels
stalin paul pott you name them genghis
khan
unless i unless my reading of genghis
khan is different from most people's i
guess he wasn't a particularly pleasant
guy
um but you know if we statues to those
kind of people
um you know
take them down uh uh because there's
nothing
really positive to be said about them
the residents of ulaanbaatar are not
going to be happy
they've got a massive statue of genghis
khan do they really oh yeah absolutely
humongous okay can i just take this
off the list but then surely isn't the
counter point to this niger what you've
just said
so for instance cromwell we have in
front of parliament now
i have a few irish friends and they
would get very upset at the thought of
cromwell being celebrated
okay but no so my point was at the
extremes you've got these these
nasty guys but for most people most
other people are a mixed bag
so yeah for the irish cromwell means
means
disproportionate slaughter but that's
not why he's in front of parliament
he's from the parliament because he
stood up to
um an absolutist king
and and um i mean
cromwell is a complicated character but
in the kind of liberal figure story he
represents
he's standing there because he
represents successful opposition to
to unaccountable absolutist
monarchy right so we got rid of that so
that's why it's there
um and there's another interesting point
about
um british public statuary um
um apparently you've got you've got
cromwell
outside of the house of commons but
somewhere else in
in in the square you you've got some i
look at who he is now
there's some irish patriot or someone
who stood up for irish home rule
in the same square and you've got
churchill but then
you've got gandhi and you've got link so
you since
the public the public statute represents
a kind of
it's eclectic it's not it's not a one
particular point of view
it is plural it's liberal it it
engenders a kind of
conversation and dialogue across across
the public square
i think that that's really healthy
because um
most people who did bad things have
something good to be said for them
and most good people who do good things
have something bad to be said for them
um and if we're gonna have any statutory
at all we've got to put up with people
who
whose records were mixed and cromwell
was certainly one of those
i just don't think that adolphs record
was quite so mixed
it's rather heavier one side than the
other yeah you know even if he did get
the trains run on time
um the problem was problems where the
trains were going
yes well well put but i i think the
point
you're really making is the tapestry of
an individual's history and our human
history is never woven just from one
fiber from one color it's always
multifaceted
and multicolored and to pretend
otherwise is very naive and i think
we're going through a bit of a period
where
there's a sort of puritanism about
everything yeah there is uh
um which i i find it
i find that i mean the the phenomenon of
this puritanism really strange the
extremity of it
uh i mean i'm a religious person i'm
i'm a christian you know so i do believe
in good and evil
but um part of my world view is that
um you know good and evil the
the divining line isn't here i'm good
and you're bad
the dividing line is here it's here
so so that you know not knowing
constantine that you're you know
you're you're you you you may be wicked
but you're not that wicked and besides
i'm wicked too
it means that means like even if i
dislike
what you're saying uh there's a certain
kind of self-restraint
i i can't bin you or demonize you
um and so i find the extremism
uh of this um it's almost and i've said
this before
it's as if the the the the social
justice warriors the
the woke folk you know they've got the
the uh um the ire of the biblical
prophets
who are railing against various forms of
injustice what they don't have
um is the notion of
of the wickedness that is within and
requires forgiveness
so it's kind of lopsided biblical
religion and they
the certainty of it the extremity of it
does give it a kind of religious
a kind of scary religious quality that
uh deserves a bit of analysis actually
but doesn't it also reflect a lack of
humility
and that you know and the realization
that we're all flawed we're all broken
none of us is perfect
and this desire to find full faults with
others and you know fling them up on the
metaphorical pyre is
yeah oh well for sure no humidity is is
lacking big time and the notion
is it's not just other people who have
to ask for forgiveness um
um and quite quite how we got there
i i do find all the puzzling
although i mean i've read a bit about um
uh what is it is it
i've forgotten the source now but there
is this
attitude or this view that um
i guess it's a marxist view
that um
points of view particularly points of
view held by
bourgeois people um these are these
these are not
taking the face of value these are just
rationalizations for unjust
interests and therefore you don't you
don't take the ideas seriously
what you do is you attack the person in
the social standing
and that seems to be behind a lot of the
attitudes of
of um
these zealous
uncompromising um new puritans
um the problem is
you know if you think about it if you
take that view
because it applies to yourself too it's
not
why is it just their view that is is
rooted in
illegitimate economic interests how
about your own views that don't you have
interest too that
you're rationalizing whatever uh
actually i think in the case of
blm i think yes there are interests here
i mean
it's a victimhood is a political
tool now it it wins you power
so there's every everyone who can has an
interest in playing victim
big time because um
particularly because of the way in which
well-meaning um sensitive
liberal people react which is normally
to say yes
it gives you a lot of power so uh i
think the the the
the kind of um marxist analysis can be
turned back
uh onto them to say well what are the
interests that are driving you
so that you simply can't listen why
and and do you see that as a more
prevalent attitude amongst
uh the students that you see here well
none of my my students
um
[Laughter]
you know they know who i am they come to
me for a reason um
uh but but i'm i have asked that i i've
asked my students about their peers
and yes the kind of uh the kind of
puritan extreme
uncompromising attitudes
yes seem to be quite prevalent among
their peers
um nigel there's one other topic i want
to cover before we wrap up but just on
that point are we not three crusty
old men that are just reminiscing about
the good i mean we're not quite
uh crusty enough
who are lamenting the loss of our ease
with which we could spew our
white supremacist beliefs unchecked
uncontrolled
unquestioned and now we're as you
pointed out earlier in the interview
we're
very upset about the loss of this form
of tyrannical oppression and power over
others is
are we not troubled by the fact that
there's some brown faces oxford now
isn't that really what this is all about
uh yes right so that's that's what they
say um that's what they say
so the answer is no um
uh because i first speak for myself
i guess others will have to judge this
but uh speaking for myself
it's not it's not criticism that bothers
me
it's not country views that bothers me
it's not
the presence of brown skins that bother
me um
it is the um
well it's it's it's it it's refusal to
engage
rationally with what i say it's the
tendency instead to attack my person
um
and let's be clear here
you say it might be the case i'm just
bothered by the fact that uh
uh there are more women and more people
of non-white skin who are inhabit
these um uh
these cloisters these these uh these
colleges
are universities might be that but
here's the thing
not every brown person thinks as they do
i mean
there's a lot a lot of people in norway
is going to agree with me
so i'm not i'm not i
i couldn't care less what skin color
people are i really i really couldn't
uh all i care about is uh whether
um they can behave and argue
in a civil fashion
and a reasonable one in which we respect
each other enough to take each other's
reasons seriously
and by all means show me where i'm wrong
you're talking about good faith
conversation
i'm talking about good faith
conversations um you should go on
twitter
i have it's not good for coc it's not
good for conversation either no
oddly enough but nigel you brought up
a point which i think is fundamental to
the current cultural moment it's
something i've been thinking about for
some time
and it's been worrying me for some time
and what
what i'm talking about is the fact that
all of these things that we are
alluding to and talking about throughout
this interview are fundamentally
anti-west
it's about the tearing down of the
liberal
the kind of the traditional world order
the capitalist
liberal in in our in our time american
world order
why why do we
feel this way about ourselves why do we
have to
uh remove as or think about removing
uh rule britannia from the last night of
the proms why
why have we come to this point where a
healthy self-criticism has
has turned into a sort of self-loathing
uh another excellent question which
which um
needs a lot of thinking about um
so here's here's one answer to to that
question
um and it goes back to something i said
earlier um
a lot of those who feel instinctively
embarrassed about
britain's past don't know very much
about it
right what they do know is
and they've learnt this from other
people
they know that talking about empire
talking up
empire doesn't mean new friends
[Music]
so so they they've picked up the the
notion that
to to talk positively about
empire about colonialism is as as my
my failed friend said toxic
and unless you want to fight unless you
want to risk losing
friends and colleagues you won't do it
therefore the impression that
empire equals evil becomes more and more
embedded because
no one contradicts it and everyone
repeats it so it's kind of
self-confirming and it kind of
gains a momentum so beca it becomes like
common sense
and so when people like me
start to say well no not just shame also
pride
people are shocked um
because it's almost as if you said
something really rude
um so i think it's partly that uh over
time
a common sense about empire and
colonialism has grown up among us
that is not all wrong but in
in significant parts it is wrong it's
just incorrect
it's not historically true um
and so but but i think you know we are
seeing
certainly over over the promised
decision to uh
um take the words out of land of hope
and glory and rule britannia
uh we're seeing quite a strong popular
reaction i mean that may have made sense
to bbc people talking to
to um um musicians from finland
it doesn't make so much sense to
[Music]
uh well i'm guessing here but judging by
the times newspaper from the telegraph
and i imagine the sun isn't terribly
happy about it
uh to most british people that this just
doesn't make sense
so so um you know when you talk about
how
how do we get to this position well who
are we here
uh and i i think we are talking about
the elite
people who run our institutions people
educated in universities
in this place um but we are you know
as with as over brexit we're discovering
that what the elite
assumes and what the rest of the
population thinks are not the same thing
um so again i'm quite hopeful that that
um you know the bbc has suddenly
discovered that not everyone is happy
with this policy
and it's it's offered some explanations
that uh
i think don't make much good sense and i
think it's true that the bbc
caved in to the um
the movement to decolonize um
and now it's having to think again
because people have spoken up uh
um so so it's to be hoped that um
we in the elite i'm part of it
um having me confronted with concrete
views will start to think again
um and i'll certainly do my part to
help that happen it's fantastic
we've got time for one last question
yeah and the question that we always end
with is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about but we really should be
that's a very good question i'm so glad
you warned warned me about it at the
beginning so i had that don't give away
the secrets of the show
nigel you could have got so much more
credit if you just pretend that you're
no doubt forthcoming brilliant answer
came to you just in the moment
you edit this bit out fantastic that's
um straight away i would have said
and i will say virtue is what we don't
talk about
um so we talk a lot about rights we know
all about rights
claiming my rights we don't talk about
virtue and i i've talked about it
in answer to to your questions uh
because i i i talked about the
importance of universities forming
students so that they can
manage a discussion of controversial
topics
in a civil fashion so they can do
justice
to what other people are saying doing
justice is a virtue it's a habit you do
or you don't
i could have also said uh treating
alien points of view with charity
meaning you know
if you hear someone saying something you
don't like
well an easy thing to do is to
caricature it knock it down
uh um a more courageous
generous charitable thing to do is okay
give it its best construction now what's
the best thing that can be said in favor
of this ridiculous point of view
then take it down um that means two
things it means first of all you've been
generous to the other side they might
actually listen to what you've
got to say because you've been generous
the other thing is
that when you take it down it's all the
stronger because you have taken its best
construction
and taking it apart and there's of
course a third possibility which is you
might by giving it
that charitable interpretation recognize
the truth and some of it
absolutely right good
back to my point uh so so
um the the disposition to do justice and
to be charitable
these are these are not technical skills
they're virtues
and that they're taught by i think
mainly by example
so professors and ceos
um can can teach their people
this is the way we behave um but these
are virtues
we don't talk about virtues we only talk
about rights and we need to learn to
talk about virtues
do we have time can i give another
example yes okay
so here's an example of why virtue is
important and why
we need to talk about it um
when was it was it five years ago when
uh
the um islamic terrorists burst into the
offices offices of charles hebdo in
paris and slaughtered
the people 2015 thereabouts was in
january i think
um and and this is because charlie hebdo
had published
um cartoons
muhammad and i think one of them had you
know
had mohammed with a turban and a bomb in
it so you know islam equals terrorism
that kind of thing
and and the the murders were terrible
they made me clear completely
unjustified
and in the aftermath of that you know a
lot of people were talking up you know
freedom of speech i mean
charlie hebdo should have been allowed
to do whatever they've done well please
and if they want to publish
um stuff that muslims find offensive
then let them do it
and my reaction was well yes but
um
my view is that it's never it's never
right
to say something to do something just to
be offensive
i mean if there's a truth you want to
speak
speak it if it happens to be offensive
too bad but it's it's the speaking of
the truth that's really what's important
uh you shouldn't you know getting people
upset shouldn't be the point
and um so my view is
you know spitting on other people's
sacred cows for the sake of seeing them
get upset
is not something we should do
what did charlie hebdo think it was
going to achieve in
publishing these cartoons now charlie
hebdo is read by people who
you know on the off the left who who
like iconoclasm particularly if he's
anti-religious
so it would please their customers
but in terms of you know what's it going
to achieve that's worthwhile
wasn't clear to me there was anything to
be achieved particularly in the context
where you know you've got to get get
muslims upset now even if you don't
agree with me on that the point is this
having the legal freedom to say
something is one thing
that's important uh the question of
whether you should use that freedom or
not is another question
and um to use that freedom responsibly
you have to have certain qualities of
self-restraint uh you have to have
certain qualities of intention i mean
why am i doing what am i trying to
achieve
um and we want citizens who are
capable of restraining themselves from
the temptation we all have
just to push in the other person's
sensitive spot because we would like to
hurt them and
irritate them we know i enjoy that
occasionally
uh but you know it's it doesn't really
help folks
um but we need citizens who are capable
of that self-restraint
and that's a matter of virtue not a
matter of rights
and and we need training in that we need
institutions
and heroes and parents
who who train us in those virtues so
i'd say in response to your question we
need to talk about virtue more now
let me be clear i think
all the qualities i mentioned i don't
need to explain to them
what they are or why they're good you
recognize them so we will recognize
these qualities are important
but we don't name them uh they're not
skills they're virtues
and i think the fact we don't talk about
them means
we're not as self-conscious about
cultivating them
so it's not as if they're absent but
we're kind of tongue-tied
and we need to stop being tongue-tied
about virtue i think so it sounds to me
nigel what you're really talking about
there is morality
as is your job and you want to talk
about
and essentially what i'm hearing is for
a healthy society it's not enough
for us just to have laws and to
prosecute our rights under those laws
we have to have a sense of what is the
appropriate thing to do
as well as what is the legal thing to do
yeah yeah
yeah notice notice that you use the word
appropriate
not right and again that's something we
we tend to talk about things being
appropriate rather than
or inappropriate and right wrong so
that's that's part of the symptom of our
kind of nervousness about talking about
moral things or virtues or duties but
but
just to get to your to your point um
yeah the the the problem with depending
more and more on law
to keep us in order and i do think we're
doing this
more and more is
partly that
if the police are going to keep us in in
in order
then they have to become ever more
intrusive
and that means that our failure to
discipline ourselves
our need for the law to discipline us
means an ever-growing
state intrusiveness which is is not a
good idea at all
so i do think that um
civil society uh fostering
moral virtues of self-restraint of
justice
of charity humility is enormously
important and and
the state can't do that i mean maybe it
can through
uh national curricular or whatever but
in the end it's
these things are taught not by books or
in classrooms they're taught by examples
maybe they are talking classrooms by
the example of the teacher but it's the
example that is is attractive an honest
courageous just charitable person
is attractive and and kids and
employees see that and i think respond
to it so
we need to be doing that more
deliberately
and in order to be more deliberate about
it we need to be willing to talk about
it
but at the moment whereas we we talk
very freely about rights
we find it very difficult to talk about
virtues uh for reasons
i mean i think historically we could
find reasons for that
uh and and as i may have said earlier
um you know we we think that because
we're a plural society
we've got you know we've got
conservatives and and
and left wingers we've got muslims and
jews and christians we've got
atheists because we're a plural society
we can't agree on moral
things um my view on that you know we
may not agree about abortion or about
um about going to war in iraq
lots of things we don't agree about but
there are many things we do agree about
and we
we all recognize what's necessary
for um uh comfortable
peaceful um uh
non-conflictual social life and we
and when i talk about these virtues to
you you don't need
me to explain what what they are or why
they're valuable
so i think in fact we agree with a whole
lot more we just think we don't
so we just don't talk about it and i
think we do need to talk about it
so um let's talk more about virtue
sounds great nigel thank you so much for
coming on the show we really appreciate
it
and i hope you've enjoyed it at home as
well uh and we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode or a live
stream which are always
at 7pm uk tom thank you very much and
see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word